we move from DeSantis to Trump himself
and more specifically his true social
activity Donald Trump posts these video
statements talking about different
things
um often ranting about different
subjects this is kind of I guess his
primary form of campaigning because most
of the time he's just golfing and this
one on true social that we'll watch is
titled sometimes you have to put them in
their place and it's him lashing out at
the lower poll number uh candidates in
the GOP Primary field right now and I
guess answering the question
that he feels he's getting asked of why
are you attacking people who have really
low poll numbers ignore them and he's
saying this is why
um in
in
traditional bunkers deranged Trump
fashion say don't punch down when
talking about people like Chris sununu
or sloppy Chris Christie or Ada
Hutchinson I call him Ada not ASA
because of certain reasons
or others but sometimes it's necessary
to talk badly about those that for no
reason
other than politics speak badly about
you otherwise
the people that love you don't know
whether or not they're for real are they
saying the truth they're not so
sometimes you have to punch down and you
have to say what's happening otherwise
they won't understand it's not fair to
them
you have to put them
in proper perspective these bad people
you have to put them in their place
people like this are very destructive
and you have to tell the voters what
it's all about otherwise why should they
be able to understand it thank you very
much
so what he really means because I agree
that you have to tell voters why you're
better than other candidates but what he
really means in punching down is he has
to
scream that uh someone like Chris
Christie is really
dishonest and is sloppy Chris Christie
such a strange people forget that oh
apologies guys get this next video
queued up for you
um he has to say all that because as he
said otherwise people might think that
Chris Christie's statements about Trump
might be for real and this is Trump's
whole Playbook anyone who says something
slightly negative has to become an enemy
because then in the minds of his
followers it's really easy to think okay
I don't have to listen to the very
accurate criticisms coming from Chris
Christie because he's an enemy he's in
the enemy category he's sloppy Chris
Christie
such a strange nickname or Ada
Hutchinson or whoever
um and that's why he has to do that
because often they're saying very when
these Republicans finally turn on Trump
they'll say things that do need to be
heard by Trump's followers rare things
being said by people at least
um rare things to hear within the GOP
about Trump that are accurate his threat
to so many things our Democratic
institutions being such a prominent
example and finally someone in the
primary field like Chris Christie is
calling that out and others
um and then this was on Ron DeSantis
specifically that Rhonda sanctimonious
was a big lockdown man here let me start
this from the beginning people forget
that Rhonda sanctimonious was a big
lockdown man early on as Governor he
locked it down and other Governors that
were Republican of nature did not lock
down if you look at South Carolina and
Tennessee and South Dakota and others
they didn't lock down but Florida was
locked down he locked it down okay we'll
stop that one there
uh
it's interesting we talked about
yesterday the very
concerning
um
characteristic of this primary that's
getting developed where DeSantis and
Trump are going to try to argue over who
was the most irresponsible in their
handling of govid who rejected the
science the most who was against taking
precaution and did we take incorrect
ones here and there and did tons of
politicians make bad decisions and
hypocritical decisions and all of that
yes but does that mean we should have
gone erratically in the direction that
maybe DeSantis Wishes the country had
gone uh no and now because the sentences
attack line against Trump is he was too
profound she and he was
pro-lockdown Trump has to turn around
and go no DeSantis was and they have to
argue about who took the science the
least seriously which is a really
strange
strange thing to be developing quickly
just to wrap up our discussion about
this primary the indictment
interestingly the set the second
indictment the federal one is having an
effect on the Republican primary not in
a huge way but at least in some way that
is negative so this is from CNN a
foreign president Donald Trump support
appears to have softened following his
indictment arrest on federal charges
according to a new CNN poll
conducted by SSRS and we'll look at
first the whole country and then the GOP
specifically most Americans approve of
Trump's indictments stemming from his
alleged mishandling of classified
documents after leaving office even as
71 percent say politics played a role in
that charging decision though Trump
continues to lead the GOP field by a
wide margin in the race for the
Republican party's nomination for
president the poll suggests that his
support has declined as a positive views
of him among Republican and Republican
leading voters nearly a quarter now say
they would not consider backing his
candidacy under any circumstances the
survey also finds that those GOP aligned
voters not currently backing his 2024
bid have different views on his
indictment and behavior than those in
his Corner that's pretty obvious and
then here's the notable
part overall 47 of Republicans and
Republican leading registered voters say
Trump is their first choice in the
party's nomination for president down 53
percent in a May
CNN poll
um in additional decline in support for
Trump's candidacy his availability
rating among Republican alive voters has
dipped from 77 in May to 67 percent now
so you're seeing shifts
um in the GOP and that could be in part
one of the most notable things that has
changed over the last few months is
Trump's legal troubles and so maybe the
idea of having
even possibly a convicted felon as your
candidate Isn't So appealing to some
Republicans even though many of them as
I very much witnessed at his arrest and
arraignment outside the Miami Federal
Courthouse a couple weeks ago many of
them still are very much on board one
lady said I would vote for him even if
he's in jail I don't care but some are
shifting and that's good to see one of
our sponsors today is wild Health
founded by two Emergency Room Physicians
what wild health does is take your
genetics and Biometrics and lifestyle
data and give you tailored suggestions
to your particular situation as far as
nutrition exercise sleep and more the
idea being to help you function at your
best in a way that's actually tailored
to you you might have a specific Health
goal you want to sleep better or lose
weight or stay healthy feel good be more
active Wild health will tailor a care
plan with lifestyle interventions
instead of pills which I always prefer
as an approach wild Health pairs you
with a care team it includes a
board-certified Precision medicine
physician who you can message anytime
through the app and their newly launched
premium program actually goes further
offering concierge medicine with over 15
specialized testing options you can look
at epigenetics a coronary CT scan and
many other things the results are
compelling many patients have seen
improvements to diabetic markers or
reducing risk of cardiovascular disease
and more wild Health has 10 new spots in
their premium program for my audience go
to wildhealth.com premium to apply for
membership the link is of course down
below